dr. who is back with another New Year
special that leaves a lot to him back
from it throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the episode as well as
wife could have in store for the new
Time Lord there will of course be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want to
know anything about the special then I
highly suggest that you turn off now but
for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I ruin it so you don't
have to do after an enemy so terrible
that it almost ravaged the world is two
feet in battle custodians of its corpse
severed it into three pieces and spread
the part that opposite ends of the earth
in the ninth century however this plan
was foiled on the outskirts of York by
robbers who murdered one of the
custodians and caused a segment of its
body part to remain in the ground away
from the sacred shrine these robbers
were unaware of the quest and the
stopping of the separation comes to
fruition in the New Year special after
the body part in Sheffield is unearthed
in modern day it causes the other pieces
to reanimate this alerts the doctor who
is currently celebrating New Year
throughout the galaxy with her
companions when she arrives at the scene
she discovers that the squid-like
creature that was revealed to be the
specimen has apparently escaped into the
city through the sewers and the main
thrust of the episode involves the
doctor trying to track down the creature
which is revealed to be a Dalek the
Dalek has attached itself to one of the
investigation officers named Lin at the
scene and is now controlling her and her
motor functions using her body to
complete its plan to take over the world
the Daleks are of course the Nemesis of
the doctor and have played the character
for eternity normally they appear
encased in their famous metal shell but
this one is without it and infinitely
more dangerous due to its ability to
attach to humans along the way Orion's
father returns and our heroes discovered
that the Dalek was actually the first
Dalek to ever reach the planet as a
recon scout the Dalek reassembles its
armor after regaining its gun and makes
a DIY suit with the Dalek being out in
the open so long it has weakened and Lin
is able to detach from it the
celebrations are short-lived however and
the dollar gets back into its suit in
one of the best scenes in the special
the doctor explains that humans will
always band together to fight against
the Daleks and reveals herself as the
doctor which sends the monster into a
rage the Dalek reveals that it wants to
summon an invasion army and escapes
battling the British Army before flying
to GCHQ to send a signal the doll
accepts all the power from Wi-Fi 4G you
name it basically Millennials of the
world despair but the doctor confronts
the Dalek head-on and using Ryan's
father's microwave they destroyed the
creatures Armour this causes it to take
Ryan's father hostage and puts the
doctor in a situation where she has to
take it to the Dalek fleet instead she
takes it to a son going supernova that
strips it from Ryan's father's back with
a little help from Ryan the episode
closes with Ryan's father leaving the
group and the doctor announcing that
they are going to go everywhere whilst
this is a happy ending
it still teases the fact that the Dalek
fleet is still out there in the galaxy
even though the signal was stopped the
other two elements of the Dalek were not
destroyed and these parts could easily
continue the journey that the main part
did obviously this could be a huge part
of the rest of the season and I can't
wait to see how this plays out
especially with the doctor being now so
dead-set that she wants to destroy them
so what were your thoughts on the Doctor
Who special and are you enjoying jolly
whicker's betrayal as the iconic
character comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and check out my
breakdown of this holidays other big TV
event black mihrab and snatch which will
be linked at the end shout out to the
cameo this is a channel for people who
are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best I'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]